[Applause]
[Music]
so as the original sin event begins to
wind down the series begins to come to a
close what we see here is that there's
going to be an answering of questions
more specifically Nick Fury is going to
give us a little more information
regarding regarding his relationship
with The Watcher now for the most part
he's not going to answer the question of
Black Panther directly that is to say
what did Nick Fury have to do with the
death of The Watcher but we're more or
less gonna get an answer to this
question at the end of the comic in
addition Nick Fury is going to explain
to us why it is that he's so old now
what it is that it happened to him and
we're gonna get a better understanding
of just what it is that Nick Fury is
capable of and what we see going on as
this story begins to open up is that the
orb is somehow transforming something is
happening to him and he doesn't quite
know what it is he simply just describes
it as his insides being on fire
we see Doctor Strange reacting to this
and asking what it is is happening to
the orb and where it is that the Nick
Fury life model decoys are taking him
that he's a witness to murder and that
he needs to stay there so that he can be
questioned properly we see that Bucky
Barnes replies by saying they're not
taking him anywhere that they're going
to keep him here and so people start
getting some answers and of course we
see Moon Knight say the Bucky really has
no grounds here because Bucky had
destroyed his ship what we also see
going on is that Black Panther continues
to create this case continues to ask
this pressing question of Nick Fury of
what is it that he did to The Watcher
what happened to The Watcher why is it
that some of Nick Fury's
gamma-irradiated bullets were dug out of
the skull of the watcher and what Nick
Fury tells us here is that his
relationship with The Watcher was
something that was questionable it was a
circumstance whereby neither of them
really liked each other due to the very
basis of the Watchers existence and what
it is that he does and the fact that
Nick Fury almost felt like the watcher
was hounding him that the watcher was
constantly monitoring him and waiting
for him to presumably die and what we
did here is a flashback to a few weeks
ago and what this flashback tells us is
two main things the first thing is that
the age difference between Nick Fury a
few weeks ago and Nick Fury at the
current time is significant indicating
that Nick Fury has aged by decades over
the course of a few weeks what he also
tells us here is that Nick Fury appears
to be dying Nick Fury appears to be
succumbing to the fact that he's aging
rapidly and so his body is catching up
with the fact that he's growing old very
very fast but what we also see here is
that the watcher is watching him that
who watched the watcher is simply just
hovering in his presence
but again the watcher doesn't really say
anything so we don't know what his
motives are we don't know if he's simply
just waiting for an expiry to die we
don't really know what the case is here
but for the most part the watcher only
appears in times of major upheaval major
instances where there's going to be some
sort of catastrophic earthbound event
and so the death of Nick Fury could very
well trigger this we're not exactly sure
what this means but what we learn here
is that Nick Fury says that if the
Watchers watching him and that must mean
that it's inevitable that he's going to
die but Nick Fury refuses to Nick Fury
refuses to accept the fact that he's
going to die here he said that he simply
just has too much more to do that he's
not going to die at the feet of the
watcher presumably because of the fact
that he hates the watch he would feel
like maybe it's some sort of
acquiescence he says that his works not
done that there's so much to do that he
has to protect the world no matter what
the cost is even to himself and so what
we get is this transition back to the
current day and Nick Fury simply tells
Bucky Barnes and others listening that
he's dying that the Infinity formula
that had existed within his body is now
used up now Nick Fury previously did
have extra batches of the Infinity
formula but this had simply been used by
I believe Bucky Barnes in order for Nick
Fury to assist in Bucky Barnes staying
alive due to some injuries that he had
received and so for Nick Fury right now
there's no escape there's no getting
away from the inevitable outcome that he
is going to die of old age he says that
every morning he wakes up that he's just
a little bit older and then he doesn't
think he has much longer what we also
see here is Doctor Strange kind of
challenging this dr. strange asking Nick
Fury if this is some kind of deathbed
confession that he recruited all of
these individuals that he brought them
all along strung them along on these
series of investigations
for Nick for them to realize that Nick
tree was the person who had been
committing all these crimes and that
maybe this was simply a cry for help
this was Nick Fury trying to get
everybody to notice what it was that he
has done Nick Fury says this isn't
really the case he says that none of
them are here by chance that all of them
are here with the exception of Rocket
Raccoon that all of them are here
because of their capabilities because
Nick Fury specifically chose them which
is the reason why they were organized
and it kind of teams that they were he
says that some of these individuals are
his friends that some he only knows by
reputation and the some of them Odette's
while others don't owe him anything
they're simply just individuals that he
considered to have been capable of
coming along for whatever this
investigation would eventually yield he
also speaks directly to Black Panther
saying that some of them are without a
doubt the smartest and most capable
people on the face of the earth and what
he says is that the reason why he
brought them on this investigation is
not because he wanted to be caught is
not so that so he could be stopped so
that he could be replaced is his
argument he wants one of them to step
forward he wants one of them to take on
the role of being the man on the wall or
even the woman on the wall someone who
is going to protect the planet Earth
from this idea of some kind of external
or internal threat that would challenge
the way of life on the planet Earth what
we see here is a transition we see that
we now join Captain America Black Widow
Wolverine and iron men as they are
investigating the body that was
discovered after Bucky Barnes had killed
Nick Fury and what they see here is that
this is a life model decoy and it's not
actually Nick Fury Tony Stark he also
goes as far as to say that it's the most
sophisticated life model decoy that he
had ever seen we see Captain America
reaction to this by simply saying that
he can't believe that he was fooled by
Nick Fury like this that they had spoken
with this life model decoy and had done
it with a life model decoy a few nights
ago and so the fact that the life model
decoy was so true that it seems so I
guess exact and really had all the many
reasons of Nick Fury down is a testament
to how far the life model decoy project
has come in addition we see Black Widow
asking the question that if Nick Fury is
not dead then where is
see that he's getting a I'm sorry she's
getting a dozen different emergency
numbers for Nick Fury that she's
contacting them but then nothing's
happening he's not answering any of them
that all his known safe houses are empty
and so the question becomes what's going
on here what is taking place in this
entire event what we also see is
Wolverine saying that the Punisher and
Doctor Strange are off the reservation
the various other individuals are no
longer conducting their investigations
and that the The Punisher had shot the
Incredible Hulk through a wall and he
says that this is a kind of operation
that is indicative of something that
Nick Fury would run this is the kind of
thing that Nick Fury would would in fact
direct and so what we see is that
Captain America asks Iron Man if he has
the ability to track down where this
life model decoy came from Iron Man
attempts to - more or less I guess maybe
accessed the circuitry or to somehow tap
into the the computer chip and the mind
of the life model decoy but when he does
the life model decoy explodes what we
see here is Black Widow asking what that
was and Iron Man replies by saying that
it was some kind of a self defense
mechanism this was designed to activate
should the life model decoy ever be
breached in terms of its uh via the
breachers attempt to access its internal
workings or even its computer chip and
so what we see is that a Tony Stark says
that before it blew up that it had sent
a signal and that he's able to trace the
signal and he says that everybody needs
to pack their oxygen tanks because
they're going into space from here we
see Captain America telling everybody
they need to assemble whoever they can't
they need to assemble virtually all
forms of the Avengers all the Avengers
that currently have that do exist or
currently have existed in the Marvel
Universe need to be brought together and
he simply says this by Avengers Assemble
from here we transition back to Nick
Fury on the space station along with
very other various other superheroes and
of course we pick up with him with the
explanation of Nick Fury and him telling
them that he wants one of them to be the
last man or woman on the wall and what
we see a Scott Lang replying to the
Scott Lang finds are very hard to
believe that he's somebody who would be
capable of being the man on the wall
that for whatever reason he doesn't seem
to possess the kind of four
tude or the willingness to kill that
would be necessary to to play this role
we see that Nick Fury telling Scott Lane
not to doubt himself that Scott Lane has
the ability to carry out this kind of a
role even if he doesn't necessarily
believe it himself in addition we see
that dr. strange says that he thinks
that maybe the physical conditioning of
Nick Fury has affected his mind that for
whatever reason he's not necessarily
functioning the way that he's supposed
to he's somehow maybe looking at things
weird he says there's no need for this
kind of a role to be played out that the
super heroes have fought various foes
day in and day out and they've succeeded
in defeating pretty much all of them and
while some weren't defeated immediately
they were to feed it in the long run but
what we see a Nick Fury doing is
replying to this by saying that someone
who's been and had the kind of
experience that that dr. strange has had
really shouldn't be this naive and that
the fact that Nick Fury was out there
being the man on the wall and disjoined
the foes that Nick I'm sorry that dr.
strange and these individuals weren't
even aware of is a testament to the fact
that one they don't understand the
bigger picture and to his actions
allowed them to be naive his actions
allowed them to play this role of saying
that they defeated pretty much anybody
not realizing they hadn't defeated all
the foes that were out there from here
we see that Black Panther goes as far as
to say that he's going to ask Nick Fury
one last time he's going to ask Nick
Fury who killed the watcher from here we
see that Nick Fury realizes that one of
the life model decoys the life model
decoy that was accessed by Iron Man
Captain America Black Widow and
Wolverine had self destructed and so he
says they're simply not much time left
that they're going to have to hurry
things along and so what we see is that
he uses his walking stick to electrocute
Bucky Barnes from here we see the other
life model decoys activate and they
begin to turn guns on these superheroes
what we also see going on is Nick Fury
taking the eye of the watcher from Bucky
Barnes and we see that again Doctor
Strange says that Nick Fury needs to
stop this that Nick Fury needs to
understand that what he's doing what
he's doing here is an effect turning
arms against the superheroes and that
there's no possible way that he could
succeed here
but what he says is that he has thought
about this he's thought about this for a
very long time that he's going to die
and that the job still needs to be done
he said that he has a world to protect
and that's exactly what he's going to do
what we also see is that Nick Fury says
that before he dies before this event
comes to an end that hopefully one of
these superheroes will be able to
understand the role that needs to be
played and they will undertake the role
of being the man on the wall at this
point we see that again
Black Panther says that if that's the
way it's going to be then that's fine he
said that he tried to reason with Nick
Fury he tried to get an egg theory to
discuss what it was it happened with The
Watcher dying of his own accord but the
fact that he chose not to it means that
he now has to take some kind of physical
action which he does and we see the
superheroes begin to attack the life
model decoys from here we jump to - Nick
Fury as he's reentering his I guess
going back into his laboratory and what
we see is that he approaches the orb and
the orb says that he thinks he's
beginning to change that he's like a
Calla pillar a caterpillar with an
eyeball for a head and that he's
changing into something new now whether
this is true or not as something that we
don't know we don't really know what it
is this taking place with the orb all we
know is that for some reason he's
reacting to the eyes of the watcher in a
way that nobody else really has while
other individuals like the mindless ones
took on some sort of telepathic
abilities or took on enhanced mental
powers more so than they had ever
previously had that the orb is somehow
changing physically that his body is
physically reacting to this we see that
Nick Theory begins to assault the orb
and begin to try to get information out
of him specifically how it was he was
able to access the secrets of the eye
how it was it he was able to access what
it is that the eyes had seen over the
course of the Watchers existence we see
that Nick Fury continues to tell the
order they don't have time to play games
that dr. Midas is still out there and he
wants to know again how it was that the
orb managed to open the eye what we see
here is that while Nick Fury is
interrogating the orb that one of the
life model decoys approaches him and
says that they'll be here soon and if
Nick Fury should be it should get suited
up what we also see going on here is
that Nick Fury takes the eye and puts it
into a container of sorts puts it into
some kind of a box and what he tells us
here is that while The Watcher is dead
while The Watcher never really cared for
him while the water didn't really like
Nick Fury in particular that there's no
reason why the watcher secrets should
die with him and so what we basically
see Nick Fury doing here is what appears
to be putting the eye of The Watcher and
some kind of a securing container from
here we see that one of the life model
decoys who is continuing to fight the
super heroes outside of this laboratory
door that Nick Fury has locked tells
Scott Lang that they have to understand
what Nick Fury was doing that the truth
is that Nick Fury was simply trying to
save the world from here we see that
this life model decoy has for the most
part been destroyed and that Doctor
Strange is trying to open the door to
the laboratory but the laboratories
appears to have some kind of magical
safeguards and Doctor Strange is curious
as to how it was Nick Fury was able to
do this how he was able to safeguard
against the magic that dr. strange
possesses what we also see is that while
these individuals are trying to break
into this room that dr. strange using
the third eye realizes that they may not
necessarily have to be the ones to break
in there that for the most part help is
on the way and what we see is that the
life model decoys are reacting to the
fact that there's been a whole breach in
Sector nine and they begin to activate
all of the existing life model decoys on
the space station from here we see that
a full full organization or a full
grouping of the Avengers have arrived
and we see the Falcon Thor The
Incredible Hulk spider-man Miss Marvel
Iron Man and various other individuals
as they begin to descend upon the
satellite and effectively do the best
they can to more or less destroy Nick
Fury or to the very least bring a stop
to his actions from here we see that
Captain America demands of one of the
life model decoys the location of Nick
Fury where the real Nick Fury is and to
tell him that the Avengers are here he
says that there's no more secrets so
there's not going to be any more lies
from here we see that there's some sort
of flash of bright light and some
individual says no more secrets and that
they agree
and that apparently so does everybody
else and what we see going on here is
that Nick Fury arrives in his complete
suit saying that his eyes are all open
and what we see is that Nick Fury
actually has both eyes of The Watcher
indicating to us that it was in fact
Nick Fury himself who had actually been
the one to kill the watcher from here
we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end and what we're gonna
find out an original sin issue number
seven and especially an issue number
eight is the full story we're gonna find
the full event of what it is it's a case
why it was that Nick Fury had killed the
watcher and what it means for the Marvel
community now that The Watcher is dead
with that being said I'm gonna bring
this video to an end and I will catch
you guys later peace
[Music]